this morning on the dish the Quarry and
Chef Lulu ranta in Monson Maine ranta
was born in the Philippines and worked
as a maid with Big Dreams one was to
open her own restaurants today she's
built a unique destination the food at
the Quarry is fantastic don't get us
wrong but as we quickly learned many are
also drawn simply by the chance to be
around the one and only
Chef Lulu
at the Quarry we were expecting great
food
we also got the best hello of the Year
hello
hello come on in my kitchen oh my God Mr
glor my kitchen do I get to eat this yes
oh my goodness head sufficiently swollen
I don't know that I've been greeted so
enthusiastically before
we were more than primed for the
complete Lulu ranta experience
you call it fun dining yes not fine
dining not anymore in the beginning we
call it fine dining but then I think
people get scared because it's in Monson
Maine why would we have fine dining
was born in the Philippines where she
worked as a maid with two dreams to one
day open her own restaurants
and to own the famous car from Knight
Rider
it's so big in the Philippines and so on
Sundays Every Time come on we all watch
it so I always say Someday I'm gonna
have a car like that Hasselhoff is huge
in the Philippines big time yes who
didn't love Knight Rider in Baywatch
right I mean specially kid Michael this
is becoming tedious
met and married an American Service
member and came to the U.S they would
divorce and she would remarry Landing in
Monson Maine
she knew her stuff but wasn't exactly
getting what she wanted
a chance to run her own kitchen
wow I think maybe they just don't
believe in me or
also I'm not from here because even if I
want to work at a uh fine dining
restaurant
even though I live here they still won't
put me as an executive chef because they
would bring you know chef from other
states so that made you you had to work
even harder yes
that brought her to the Quarry name for
the areas once prosperous slate mining
operation that closed in 1943.
Munson had struggled since then but in
2018 became the lucky recipients of
millions of dollars from the non-profit
Libra Foundation which has helped
transform the town located in a
rockwellian but remotes area of Maine
into an artist colony run to Cook's
meals for Hungry painters photographers
and writers
along with dinner for tourists and
others you don't turn tables over no
when people eat why well because I want
to see my customers and I've been to a
restaurant before that I wanted to enjoy
but they're always hurrying you up so I
promised myself
if I own a restaurant they can have the
table
until we close
ready we'll do magic
before we could dig into the meal there
was one thing left to do in the kitchen
turn sugar into glass oh look yeah it's
melting it's melting is that good it is
good okay it's bubbling just one of the
many special touches ranta brings to her
Creations so so you do is drizzle it
all over yeah all over it
there we go we put them in there okay
now you can find your your glass sugar
glass in there oh wow see
and they're cool so cool now this will
stay together yeah that's so cool the
finished product we'll have to wait for
desserts in the meantime runs are laid
out one of the more colorful spreads in
recent dish history
to start a salad with yellow watermelon
feta cheese Maple mustard vinaigrettes
and her signature gelatin strawberry
diamonds
that's fantastic
strawberry I've never had strawberry
diamonds before lamb the quarine Monson
wow
up next a tuna tartare with lime and soy
dressing it's tart but good yeah yes all
right lonely yes
I don't want to say it's candy but the
tart is almost like a candy but it's not
it's not like crazy Thai yeah no not at
all it's balanced it's just a little
punch yes a little kick not a kick he
knows food I don't
there was grilled lamb with candied
pineapple and spiced plums delicious
this is your take on Duck or uh lamb
excuse me because usually they have
oh he's making I'm making him smile it's
good I have never had pineapple all
these first
I never had lamb like an Asian style
like this because usually they do like a
rosemary I love it or mint jelly or
whatever it's Best of Both Worlds yes
you're three for three three for three
oh wow in a row ronce's take on Duck
larage has pickled jicama and candied
Orange
there's halibuts seared and served with
creamy saffron risotto lemon thyme and
purple and green cauliflower look at
these yes I mean you talk about color I
love color and to round out the table
beef rare with sweet potato and a
bourbon glaze I'm cutting through it
like butter yes with like butter with a
butter with a butter knife
that bourbon glaze is awesome
honestly for desserts a chocolate torte
with vanilla cream on top and our sugar
glass with a pipette filled with sake
and Plum extract you squirt it
that was fun
[Applause]
with her success rolling ranta is in the
process of buying the Quarry from the
Libra Foundation
as for the car it's not kit but she did
get a 1995 Pontiac Firebird which she
sends passed on to her son when you look
back on that young lady in the
Philippines
did you ever imagine she'd be here
today
no I still pinched myself
you should buy a kit today
we don't need kid anymore we have Alexa
ask Alexa where to eat in Munson
and we found one great answer you are a
bundle of energy
I don't well thank you it's the joy that
you bring to this is obvious I love to
go I love to feed people
that's obvious we say this all the time
road trip yes chef you got to take us
she's fantastic maybe Lulu can join us
at the table I think she would have
given me and Dave
she's like us you'd be done yeah we'll
be right back
did you try with her to ask Alexa where
to eat and I I'd be curious so here's
what happened as I'm tracking as I was
tracking every time I track this piece
yeah when I sent tracks from home Alexa
would go off in and hopefully Alexa's
not going off in your house right now
because Alexa I would say Alexa now I'm
really messing people up at home I'm
sorry
um but it would start to mess up so then
I had to like I don't know either unplug
Alexa or do it I'm going to stop saying
it why do I keep saying Alexa the food
just looks so delicious it did I mean
that was it halibut or the fish was just
she takes it's I and I would describe
the overall restaurant as you know like
new American but it's these little
flourishes she puts on it that come from
the Philippines or her childhood or
other places that you just wouldn't
think of so you're eating stuff that is
both familiar and different yeah and I
think that's really cool yeah and and
she kicks it up all I mean to the nth
degree in a way that just um it it I
love that you wouldn't expect it in a
place like months in Maine and you may
not expect it from you know the way the
the restaurant looks from the outside
but it is fine dining it has it's very
much fine dining but and she makes
breakfast lunch and dinner wow so
fundamentally what it is is her love yes
of making food and making people happy
stay as long as you want love